this week on quadriga
online surveillance no place to hide
the nsa scandal has revealed that huge
amounts of personal information are
being gathered by democratic states
in germany this has prompted a
particularly fierce debate
data protection is a very sensitive
topic here because of abuses in former
communist east germany and the nazi era
controversially the german government
has defended the successes of u.s
surveillance in preventing terror
attacks
but do we really need big brother to be
safe from terrorism
or will total surveillance spell the end
of true democracy
and what can individuals do to protect
themselves
your host this week ali aslan
hello and welcome to quadriga the
personal fate of whistleblower edward
snowden
is uncertain but what is very certain
is that his revelations have unleashed a
wide debate
and many questions about the role of the
internet about privacy and security
questions i will take up upon with my
three guests on today's show
welcome to marcus pekidal who writes
about politics in a digital society for
netpolitik.org
it's an award-winning block which is
widely read across the german-speaking
world
he also serves as an expert to the
german parliament's commission of
inquiry on internet
and the digital society alan pozna is a
correspondent and commentator
for the german daily newspaper developed
and weld belt amzantak
he's also one of germany's most
prominent bloggers
and eric kishbaum is a berlin
correspondent for reuters
the world's largest international news
agency a u.s citizen he's been covering
german politics
since 1989.
welcome to you all gentlemen alain
posner the debate
is going on a very intense debate about
the role of the internet and certainly
about the person edward snowden himself
ever snown as we now is still stuck at
the airport
in moscow and a lot of people are still
debating and asking themselves whether
or not
he's a hero for his deeds or a traitor
now i know that you deem him to be a
traitor
why is that the case well and
technically he is a traitor
this whole talk of him as a
whistleblower is absurd
i mean i'm not you know that's not a
moral issue
people can have very good moral reasons
for being traitors
um the the spies the atomic spies of the
fifties
who gave america's atomic secrets to the
russians they thought they were helping
world peace
mr vanunu who betrayed israel's atomic
secrets to the world
thought he was doing it in the in for
the good of world peace and i suppose
mr snowden may have very i don't know
inside his head but technically
he was entrusted with secrets he gave he
said he would keep these secrets
he took a vow of secrecy and he betrayed
the trust
that was placed in him so he's a traitor
marcus pacquiaodal
would you agree with the notion that
everest known as a traitor
not really i think he's a hero he showed
courage
and he saw that something is wrong and
he said he don't want to live in a world
where every everything is being
surveilled what he's doing online
and he wanted to show the world that
it's
right what a lot of people were thinking
about
we had all the debates within the
technical community over the last years
but
edward snowden he proved it right
what we were thinking but his critics
especially in the united states are
saying that he has compromised national
security
would you agree yeah of course but also
he
saved my privacy by bringing this debate
to the world
and he certainly has brought this debate
to the world eric kirschbaum
you are you are a u.s citizen and you
are following the debates
uh even though you're based in berlin
but you're following the debate in the
united states as well very closely how
is he being perceived over there
yeah very negatively i think only about
20 of americans support
snowden most think he is a traitor i
think part of the problem is where he's
right now in moscow and he was in hong
kong and i think that adds to the
the dubious nature of it all i mean
there's a lot of americans who do
consider him to be a hero and
and he did stand up for for liberty and
that's something that does strike a
court it's a really tough issue
there's very little middle ground people
either like him or hate him
and um and he's on the run from the u.s
right now and no country will take him
in he's more or less a fugitive
and marcus pacquidal would you think and
say that
he himself did himself a disservice by
going to russia
after all a country that is not exactly
known if you will
for for exercising freedom of speech i
would be more happier
if the german government would protect
him
and give him some kind of asylum by
coming here
and talking about what he really found
out
but the german government and a lot of
other democratic countries
don't want to do it because of the
united states and the pressure from them
so i can understand him that he don't
want to go into a prison where he
might not be able to speak out what he
wants to speak out when he comes now to
the united states so
you're saying that germany should have
granted him asylum yeah isaac asylum or
some other
kind of protection to be here and to
talk to politicians to talk to media
about what he found out
and alain pozna let's talk about germany
because germany
has been very much in the focus of the
nsa now we know a half a billion of
communications been intercepted in only
one month
uh germany very much in the focus of the
nsa
but chelsea merkel after being asked
about that
in a press conference said she knew
nothing about prism
about the activities of the nsa in
germany
she lying well
i wouldn't accuse someone of lying but i
don't think she's telling the whole
truth
you know i mean there's all politicians
have this thing with
a credible deniability you have to be
able to say i didn't know about it
but the very concept assumes that you
know a whole lot of stuff
that you're not going to tell people
about that you're going to say i didn't
know about that's the way
things work we have a foreign service
agency which
um is huge they're constructing this
huge big building in
in berlin it's thousands of people it's
not nsa but
you know but it's compared to the german
populations a whole lot of people what
are they doing
now there are a million people who have
the security clearance that mr snowden
had
and if the bnd hasn't even talked if our
if our spy service hasn't even talked to
one of those
then they're not earning their pay
therefore i think yes
of course we knew about it our troops in
afghanistan were actually using prism
um and and and there's some i i would
assume that there's some kind of
uh that there's some kind of uh
deniability thing involved
where america can credibly say no i
didn't know or i didn't know everything
or this and that you know they have
these phrases it's their business to
have these phrases
let's assume let's assume she's right
let's assume she's telling the truth
that she did not
exactly know what the nsa was up to in
germany doesn't it
make it even worse if if the bnd the
german intelligence
service which has now we know has been
using the nsa software
x key score and have been cooperating
with the nsa for many years
is that even worse if the chancellor
doesn't know what the bnd is doing
well if she really didn't know that
would be really bad then the bnd would
be a state in the state but it's not the
case
of course she knew in general terms what
was going on and and not only her but
her predecessor mr
schroeder all german governments have
had some idea
of what the americans are doing and have
cooperated with the americans because
it's in our interests i thought it was
very interesting the way you
you did this when you talked about
democratic states we are democratic
states we're not
democratic states we and the united
states are fighting a war on terror
together
we are not friends with the with the
russians because they are obstructing
this war we are not friends with the
chinese
these are our friends and allies and we
cooperate and people like snowden
on people who condone his actions are
actually subverting this effort
they are they are actually friends of
freedom
we can debate about how democratic it is
if you
have as a society or you build up a very
huge surveillance program
and you have secret courts secret courts
are not
really democratic for me eric kirschbaum
let's talk about uh the german
perception again of
this nsa scandal if you will
many germans are not happy with the way
chancellor merkel is handling
uh this issue um do you think this could
affect her re-election bits it's only uh
we're only a couple of months away from
the election in september two months
away she's going on a three-week
vacation right now so she's getting away
from it as bad as
fast as she can she's keeping a lot of
distance between herself and the scandal
which is the smart thing to do
politically
um pretending she doesn't have much to
do with it when she seems to be getting
away with it her overall poll numbers
are still really good
i mean the germans are a bit
schizophrenic in this question they want
protection they don't want to be hit by
terror they're happy when eight terror
attacks are
are stopped and prevented here thanks to
these data
but then the data it comes out what's
going on and they they throw up their
arms and start screaming so
what does germany want do they want they
want some protection from terror attacks
and to be spared from terror attacks
or do they want to have 100 um privacy
and we'll talk more about the necessary
balance between privacy and security
indeed but
let's stick with the issue of privacy
and the german perception of it uh by
and large the germans are rather
sensitive when it comes to
data privacy polls show that indicate
that over and over again how about the
americans do you think the americans
differ in that regard a lot less i mean
the americans don't have the nazi past
the gestapo pass to deal with the
americans don't have the um
the stasi pass to deal with that was
just a few decades ago people were
eavesdropping and
um i mean americans loved the film the
lives of others that for them it was
incredible that something like that was
going on just a few years ago
americans don't have any kind of past of
that they have a
bit more faith in the in the government
to protect them than the germans the
germans are a lot more skeptical a lot
more leery of the snooping and the
eavesdropping that goes on
americans i think by and large would
prefer that the state is there
protecting them from 9 11 style terror
attacks
then worrying about their emails and and
phone calls being listed
i think a lot of americans assume people
are listening in any way i don't think
americans ever assumed they weren't
being listened into
and marcus began would you say that
germans are particularly sensitive
when it comes to data privacy yeah sure
we had strong
social movements in the 80s against the
folks ceylon
at the sensors you can't really compare
to
today where we are storing all kinds of
data in lots of databases but
this was one of our roots
of a data protection movement in germany
and i know
a lot of friends who grew up in the gdr
and say
now the feeling of being surveilled so
now the feeling that they can't talk in
public
whatever they want to talk it because
they know the feeling
uh how it is to live in a society where
you can't
really um use all your human rights and
say
don't want to live in that world i don't
want to live in such a world
so uh we want to be a free
in the online world too i'm shocked that
a person with i
with so little idea of what goes on in
the world is actually advising our
government and our parliament
mr vegeta germans have the most
complete record of where everyone is
when you
move to berlin or away from berlin when
you move your flat you have to register
with a extra which with an institution
a government institution which has the
addresses and names of every german
every person living in this country
americans don't have anything like that
the americans would would you know would
say what
your government knows every single
person where they live if you go to
school or send your child to school
they there is a folder on this child
with everything he or she has done
which can be seen by every teacher plus
the school secretary and goes with him
from school to school
there is total invasive uh
invasive surveillance of people in
germany which americans would
never allow yet when america tries to do
data protection then everyone is up in
arms
sorry i'm totally shocked that you bring
such uh examples
it's a different if i have to go to a
amt
and to tell them i live now in berlin
then
let's see in berlin but where exactly
totally different
comparing to data retention where it is
stored for up to six months where my
smartphone was in the last six months
and who i met
and who i was talking to it's totally
different to
within your flat most of the time where
and where you were talking to people
different too um storing all my
communication
data all my content maybe form lifelong
in the storage centers in utah and it's
different from when you as a pupil or
your son or daughter as a pupil
wrote something on the blackboard and it
comes in there in their so-called shula
actor in the pupils
file and it goes from teacher to teacher
all through their
her his or her school life and you can't
access it as a parent you can't access
it as a student but every teacher can
but no one's talking about that they're
all worried that somehow the nsa is
snooping on their stupid facebook
communication
but it's one thing if the german
government knows
uh you know knows things about its own
citizens it's another thing
if another country like the united
states is
uh spying on another country's citizens
like in this case
don't you think that germany is
undermine under money and compromising
its own sovereignty here
if it if it does nothing well of course
you
that's the point of secret services you
spy on other people that's what you have
them for
you know but there's a collaboration
between the bnd and the nsa
yeah also the bad gets information the
bmd cooperates because they want
information as well
i mean the b d is is there for a reason
as well but also to prevent terror
attacks in germany
and uh it's a two-way street it can't
just be the nsa taking information
from germany the germany gets
information as well so and the german
interior minister hans peter then said
uh security trumps everything at the end
of the day
the preventing terrorism must be the
number one priority
and trumps and precedes the right for
data privacy would you agree yeah i mean
it's really interesting watching
friedrich and pophala and miracle trying
to talk out of both sides of their mouth
trying to keep everybody happy without
really saying anything that's going to
come again come back to haunt them and
just watching them do their verbal
linguistics is fascinating because
they're they're saying a lot of words
but they're not really saying anything
that we're going to remember
and mark respected a lot of people are
saying even those who are
perhaps uh critical of the surveillance
are saying at the end of the day
i'd rather live in a society free of
terrorism and terrorism attacks i'd
rather take that
uh sort of into account that i'm that my
information
is is being looked upon if it uh
you know if you will if it helps me live
in a terrorism-free society what do you
say that
i wouldn't really agree if we want to be
in a
live in a very safe society
then maybe we should forbid cars because
there is much more damage and much more
dead people
are caused by cars than materials acts
in germany
and this is one argument the other
argument is
a lot of people don't really understand
uh how surveillance in the digital age
is happening because
somewhere stored all our communication
data maybe it's used against us
and it's a bit different to the life of
the others where someone is sitting
next door listening what you are doing
now it is data store
storages now it is algorithm listen to
your communication and
even me i as a technical person
i have or i don't really can understand
or feel it how um
how it is um 57
of americans are saying this is from a
washington post poll are saying
that the number one priority for a
government ought to be to prevent
terrorism
um is that also your take
well no actually
you know i think um the priority is to
protect life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness like i said in the
declaration of independence three things
and among them is liberty if the
government in the pursuit
of protecting life uh obviously there's
a certain amount of
uh infringement of liberty but it has to
be discussed
and that's just what happened in the in
the united states congress in the house
of representatives yesterday
and they took a vote on whether these
nsa
surveillance could go on and it was a
narrow vote and it crossed party
boundaries and that's the way it should
be instead of getting all hysterical
about it
let's discuss it but it's not happening
in germany we're getting hysterical
about algorithms where we're one of the
few countries in the world which has
an institution called fafsa it's
protection of the constitution
whose only job is to spy on its own
citizens
they spy on the left party although it
is totally legally party
operating in parliament they they run
the national democratic party through
so-called v-men right it you know and no
one's talking about that everyone's
talking about algorithms
this is you know people are talking
about for let's close the fafsa
well i'm glad to hear that from you good
there there is a sense though a lot of
people are saying
and the nsa most importantly are saying
that
many terrorist plots have been foiled
due to
surveillance but at the end of the day
it did not prevent
the attacks in boston so what does it
tell us about the
efficiency of these surveillances when
they always say there's no 100 percent
fail-proof system i mean uh i think
obama's talked about 50 terror attacks
have been prevented in the last decade
because it's difficult to verify isn't
it sure
it's a claim but um i mean any logical
thinking person would think if they're
collecting all this data they must have
stopped the few
um obama when he was here in berlin
talked about the need for a balance i
don't know at his press conference he
went on at length about this issue it
really seemed to um
to touch a nerve with him he talked
about the need to have court
court orders for these things and
i think he understands there might be a
problem with the balance it might have
gotten a bit out of control and
and all the attention that snowden has
brought up uh might refocus the debate
hey let's not go overboard even former
president bill clinton
has said uh we have to take care that we
don't let the war on terror
lead to abuses in in the privacy sphere
so who knows exactly where
the right line is the fine line is in
there somewhere maybe it has been
crossed a bit
um and this debate will is just focusing
people's attention that it is a problem
and it shouldn't go too far because i
don't think anybody in their right mind
wants a police state where everything is
being watched and snooped on i mean
there are limits nor expect how could
such a balance look like
you have to go into a detail detail
i believe that i don't want to live in a
society where
everything is being surveilled and i
when i now i'm
being surveyed i change my behavior and
if i change my behavior
in communicating online because i now
someone or a lot of people or a lot of
agencies are
storing it then i can't really use my
civil liberties
then it's not a democratic society and i
want to live in a democratic society why
not because you can't use your computer
it's not a democratic society why can't
you just meet somebody and
talk one-on-one our constitutional court
said in a ruling against the data
retention that there are some kind of
chilling effects and
these chilling effects are bad for our
society chilling effects that
if you know you're being surveyed you
change your behavior
and if you change your behavior you
think always
what you are talking and it's a
different if you're talking in
your bedroom with your wife or being
totally open
when everything is being surveyed but we
have a strong protection of civil
liberties that i
i have private spaces where i can talk
to everyone what i
really want um i'm thinking that's one
of the negative factors of this whole
thing is that
the terrorists now are changing their
behavior as well the terrorists they
have changed their behavior a lot of
people knew that
everything was being surveyed my parents
didn't knew it
now they know it because of edward
snowden intelligence agency people are
talking about how
it's harder to get information now that
the terrorists themselves
become a little more cautious yeah after
september 11
all uh intelligent terrorists
they stopped communicating digital
oh the rest didn't stop
well everyone is under surveillance says
uh marcus pacquidol which of course begs
the question
how can one prevent him or herself from
being under surveillance is there a way
for the average citizen to escape from
being in the focus
of the nsa let's have a look
governments may tell us if we have
nothing to hide we have nothing to fear
but innocent people have been caught up
in the secret services dragnet
can we do anything to protect our
privacy besides staying offline
one possible way of keeping our digital
traffic anonymous is by using the tor
network the software bounces data across
several continents to prevent the
tracking of online movements
freenet is another tool for concealing
communication
it pools storage between different
computers on the network
and doesn't use web servers at all
users include journalists and also
dissidents living under repressive
regimes
but the so-called deep web also has a
darker side
it attracts terrorists drug dealers
pedophiles
and other criminals
there is the argument being made that if
you're a law abiding citizen you
actually have nothing to worry about if
you have nothing to hide then
there is nothing to fear do you think
that argument falls short
yes it does i mean it it's obvious that
over the
not just now but in the whole history of
all democratic societies they've been
innocent victims
of of security glitches of over
enthusiastic security people especially
in germany by the way think of
general kiesling who was accused of
being a homosexual lost his job because
that was considered a
security risk i mean there was a whole
host of and he was neither
homosexual nor would homosexual mean
you're a security risk but this was just
this is in the 70s
and there's a whole lot of other people
who have who and you know and that was
without any kind of digital
uh hitch and i suppose that and i
haven't heard of any
um one complaining about about being
targeted because of
their online activities but it's going
to happen of course and you have to be
very very vigilant
i mean trust but verify you know trust
your government but you know be ready to
criticize your government when it goes
overboard on stuff like this
mark suspected we just saw in the in the
little clip that there are ways
for an individual to protect yourself
from
surveillance now i'm not a technological
expert and we
don't want to go into details but i'm
more interested in finding out who are
these people
who are these individuals who are
resorting to these measures
of of applying if you will these
technical
technical devices to prevent themselves
from being surveilled
oh these are dissidents for example
if you want to use your freedom of
expression right in
living in china and communicating with
other people outside of china or
even in china you better should use
anonymity tools
if you're a journalist and you are
journalists i assume
then you should use these tools to
protect your sources
otherwise you bring danger to your
sources so
i love napples out there the ones with
less noble intentions
they have always been in a society and
they will be
and we didn't had a surveillance state
before and there were a lot of criminals
and we got them so we will
find them in a future too eric
kirschbaum there are a lot of people
that are saying at the end of the day
the users
internet users are basically it's their
own fault because they reveal
a lot of private information on social
networks such as facebook
and and at the end of the day they don't
seem to care
they don't seem to mind that this kind
of information they voluntarily
uh put the this kind of information
online for their friends and the world
to see
so uh if i if i could ask where's the
outrage here what's the big deal
exactly it's amazing what people are
willing to put of their own personal
private life on the internet it's um
some sort of a place to put everything
about your life where you've been what
you've done your pictures for the last
20 years
it never ceases to amaze me the things i
see on facebook and the internet
so yeah that's another heavy argument
hey it's your own fault you don't have
to put this on the internet
if you want to talk to somebody go down
to the park and talk to them and you
don't have to put it all on
facebook for the world to see there
seems to be a need in people these days
to
to let it all hang out there for the nsa
to have a look at i don't know
sorry that sounds like someone who
didn't grow up with the internet
i know a lot of people who grew up with
the internet and
for these people it's uh a facebook
profile
site or another social media site it's
something like a
living room for them and uh it's more
like a feeling um there was no
generation before growing up with the
internet
and uh if you have your profile page
then you
think about it's not like a living room
at home nobody will watch through the
window or nobody assumes
watching through the window i've heard
employers people who hire people
will look at somebody's facebook page
just to find things out it doesn't have
to be the nsa it's just
a productive employee and it's dangerous
why put something that might be
prevent me from getting a job on to into
my facebook page it seems
bizarre um it's also bizarre that um
social media platforms like facebook and
don't think about privacy at the start
if you yeah it should be the opposite
then
it is now that if you start a profile
then it's whole protected against
possible
looking through the windows by your
co-workers
and you should have then the right
to switch the data protection rules of
facebook but now it's the opposite
everything is open and this is the um
as a status point mr beginner you may
have grown up with
the internet but you don't understand it
you don't understand what facebook is
all about
i do i have i don't know 1 000 so many
friends on facebook and all these people
all they want is publicity they don't
want to be sat in their living room
no one's happy just to have five friends
on facebook which you would have in your
living room they all want as many
friends and likes and this and that is
possible
they want everyone to change your
friends i have to
de-friend people every day but because
there's so many nuts out there
what i'm saying is that everyone i know
and all the people who are younger than
you on facebook
they want as many people as possible to
know about them this is the me
age this is the publicity age this is
the hang it all out page this is where
your
communication it's the age of
communication where people want to
communicate and that's a great thing of
the internet
we now well then don't talk about your
living room don't talk about your living
room
people don't want to be in their living
room they want to be stars
now there are lots of studies by
scientists uh who found out that
this feeling is in a a in the minds of
lots of people
they feel like it's their living room
their profile page because
we have to um to find out ourselves my
parents can't tell me what it is
having a facebook page i tell them what
it is well facebook is certainly one of
the companies that
has cooperated with the nsa along with
them
with microsoft yahoo google aol and
skype among
others didn't seem to have hurt them
though their stock just
gained in value uh which begs the
question once again
eric here spawn much ado about nothing
well i think so i mean i think in a
couple of months or a year or so this
will be pretty much a forgotten issue
around most of the world and germany
probably not in germany it's going to
linger for a long
time and maybe there'll be political
reverberations one day about the thing
that amazes me in germany the pirate
party
has gained no traction from this at all
why not i mean if it really is an issue
that
upsets german to the germans to the core
why isn't the pirate party profited or
made more of an issue out of it instead
people are going off on holiday miracles
going on holiday
and nobody really seems to be all that
bothered about it i don't think
marcus bekedal is this an artificial
discussion that we're leading in the
public sphere about
privacy and security placebo effect if
you will
i'm not sure it's a media topic so
journalists like to talk about it but i
think it's good
because journalists are part of a public
debate and
we bring more attention to the facts
that everything is being surveyed i
would be more happy
if my parent generation would be as
angry as i am
about beings await but maybe um
as long as we don't uh track their tv
behavior
they don't do any revolution the nsa
chief keith alexander
uh has voices surprised about
the surprise that we we in germany have
exhibited um and many people echo his
sentiments because we're saying
and i think it's been said on the show
as well we've known all along haven't we
at the end of the day we're being spied
upon nothing
on the internet is really private uh
were you
honestly and genuinely surprised about
the nsa surveillance
revelations no i started being a
political
person 15 years ago when the first leaks
about
all the surveillance programs on the
internet around ekelon
came out so i am not surprised
but i'm happy that we are now having
this debate i waited 15 years
for it marcus bechdel waited 15 years
for this debate he certainly has got it
the us patriot act which was launched
after the 9 11 attacks
which basically is the precursor if you
will to the
nsa and the prison surveillance system
many people are saying the u.s patriot
act of 2001
should be revisited that it gives the
government a blank check
to basically do whatever it wants in the
name of combating
terrorism would you agree well it's
going to be revisited i do agree
yes and it is going to be revisited uh
in the united states unlike in germany
most laws have a sundown clause that is
they expire and the patriot act is going
to expire in 2015
if it isn't renewed by congress that's
what democracy is all about
and i definitely think that in 2015 you
have to revisit the whole concept of a
war against terror
an ongoing war which has no end and so
on which has led to
stuff like guantanamo you know i'm not
someone who says
clamp down on civil liberties in the
name of security now we
security is there to protect civil
liberties so
yes let's revisit when the time comes in
2015 let's revisit the patriot act and i
should hope
that some of its more restrictive
clauses um would be
would be um maybe made more liberal i
i'm i'm sure
but it's it's about drawing the fine
line between protection we all want the
ability
to go down the street and not be scared
that the car next to you is going to
explode
and my civil liberties in on facebook
that i don't want people uh you know the
nsa to know that i actually like
i don't know madonna or whatever
i mean the patriot act was came out of
the 911 era and the 911 happened because
people seemed to be asleep at the switch
that people could just climb on a plane
with uh with knives in their in their
carry-on baggage and do what they did
america was shocked about it just really
went to the core of of the freedoms of
america they took advantage
of the freedoms that america has and
exploited it or 10 15 years later
it probably won't be extended it's a
whole new era
and the excesses of the nsa will also
come under the debate i'm sure in the
next few years
but also the boston marathon bombings
were not being
being uh right curtailing prevented if
you will at the end of the day so
you could argue that the nsa is not
being very efficient either the thing
with the boston marathon bombings it was
a small small scale operation a few
people were involved it was something
might have been below the radar
um it just might have been too small for
anybody to notice but
i'm sure something like the 911 plots
would have been picked up had the
patriot act been in place here's what
president obama said to marcus pekidow
he says
you can't have 100 percent security and
then also have 100
privacy and zero inconvenience
do you think there's some truth to his
statement we have human rights and we
have a constitution
and i uh i believe that these
surveillance programs are violating our
human rights and we should protect our
human rights
well look every time you talked about
about the the knives on the planes in 9
11.
every time you go on a plane you get
patted down it's a
very invasive procedure and not only you
not a young man who who might
possibly uh be a terrorist but a little
old ladies a grandma who's been visiting
her grandchildren and so on
not only young muslim men who are sort
of
the target but you know even my little
daughter and so on gets
her teddy bear the stuffing taken out of
it and so on but we do all this because
we'd rather arrive in one piece
firstly and secondly because we don't
want to be seen to be profiling people
so we rather go through
an invasive procedure for everyone than
to target the people we know
are more likely to do mischief and i
think that's
it's there it's the fault of the
terrorists we've reacted in a very
i think democratic way everyone has to
go through this procedure
and this is democratic that all our
communication
is stored without a suspicion
i would i would definitely say that i
prefer all our communication to be
stored than to store all communication
by muslim men under 25 yes
well uh at the end of the day though
surveillance is one measure but does it
really combat the route of terrorism at
the end of the day you can have all
those data stored
but what about the roots what about the
causes that that
lead to terrorism at the end of the day
the nsa does not address that does it no
it doesn't and it's not his job to
address that it's not the
job of the nsa to change the way people
think thank goodness it's not the job
you know i mean we know the roots of
terror the roots of terror in
may are radical fanatics they can be
radically fanatic muslims who doesn't
have to be
they've been radically fanatic
christians who bomb abortion
clinics they can be radically fanatic i
don't know what
data protection people who would like to
bomb the nsa
radical fanaticism is something you
can't root out we never will root it out
until we get to genetically engineering
people's minds
which i hope we won't do and uh
you know big brother is the victor yeah
uh
mr kirschbaum at the end of the day do
you think that these revelations
by edward snowden do you think he's
going to achieve his goals do you think
i mean we're talking about it certainly
so that's one part of him achieving his
goals but
do you think in the long run do you
think his his
revelations uh will amount to anything
substantial that it will lead to
if you will change legislation and so on
so forth he's already accomplished a lot
i think he's already been a big
corrective
he's got a lot of people thinking about
this he's got barack obama answering
long questions talking about the need
for balance i think he's accomplished
a lot he may be seen as a traitor in the
eyes of the americans but i think a lot
of americans who live abroad don't
necessarily see it quite as black and
white as that
um i think a lot of americans abroad
think that he's done some good things
and some important things and he's
i mean the guardian is a is a huge
successful popular paper a lot of
americans read the guardian
especially since 9 11 by the way they
wanted more of a balanced non-american
viewpoint and it's it's amazing to me
how popular british newspaper is the
united states
he picked the guardian out for a reason
and and there's a lot of a lot of people
in this world who
who think he has accomplished a lot and
he's not just started a debate he's got
people thinking
about hey has this gone too far are
there excesses here that are happening
mark speciadale would you also agree
that
edward snowden is coming out if you will
as a as a former agent has as uh
you know lead to to the outcome that he
desired yeah thank you edward snowden
he brought us a debate now we need to go
to go a step further
we need to change legislation we need to
have better
privacy rules on the national european
and international level we need to have
more control on our secret services
these examples show us we can't really
control them in the moment as a
democratic society but we need to have
it
and we should think about thinking
privacy by design by building up new
technologies new infrastructures in the
moment nobody
to care about privacy if you build them
in when you're designing a new
technology then it's safer for all of us
you just said all the things that need
to be done but do you actually believe
that they will be done
i hope but it's politics so
i can't really say alain posner what is
the outcome of this
uh in the long run will edward snowden
be a footnote in history or
do you think we'll remember him for a
long time to come
well he will remember him he gave
comfort to america's enemies
he exposed programs which are helping to
protect america he made america look
to some people who advise democratic
governments like
some kind of they compare america now to
a stasi state he's done
incredible damage and of course what the
as far as the secret services of all
countries are concerned they will now
just borrow deeper so he will have in
the end
been very self-defeating um
i don't think um there's anything
positive about him
and so we just had we just quoted barack
obama let's quote another great american
one of the founding fathers actually
benjamin franklin who said
that those who would give up liberty to
obtain temporary safety
deserve neither in the end
do you think he has a point well yeah of
course if you give up liberty
but every law you make you talked about
cars
you have to drive on one side of the
road you can't drive on the other side
of the road you're giving up your
liberty to drive on whatever side of the
road you like
we're talking about open spaces if we
had had more surveillance cameras on the
alexanderplatz here in berlin maybe they
wouldn't a turkish gang wouldn't have
been able to beat up a vietnamese guy
beat him to death or at least they would
have been found sooner
and so on and so on there is always a
trade-off between liberty and security
so benjamin franklin
though he was a great physicist um
discovered uh the electoral properties
of lightning and so on i don't think
that's a particularly clever quote eric
kirschbauer
it was a long time ago he said that
wasn't it before the internet
it's certainly been a long time he
hasn't been around for a while but at
the end of the day
do you think that total freedom uh as
propagated
by some is naive it's not it's not
realistic i think in this day and age
the balance
is important like obama and smart people
say that getting the balance right and
um
and if snowden is a bit of a corrective
that's probably a good thing and um to
prevent the abuses from running
getting out of control but there's a lot
of smart people thinking about this now
and talking about it and they weren't
two or three months ago so
i think the bottom line is snowden will
be more than a footnote in history
at least in germany i think he'll be a
big name for a long time and the
magazine covers for
a long time to come that's probably a
good thing and you think he will be
remembered fondly in the long run even
in the united states
no probably not i mean he is seen as a
traitor he's he's
sitting in the wrong countries at the
wrong time and um
i mean you like to think that there
might be some way
out of this the united states could
maybe put him on trial and give him a
suspended sentence or something and
it could be a happy ending but that's
probably unlikely isn't it
well whether a happy ending is likely or
not in the case of edward snowden as far
from being certain
with a happy ending as far as the nsa
and all the discussion and debate about
privacy freedom and security
is likely we will see and we will of
course continue to
monitor and continue to observe this
story for now i want to thank my guests
for their
input for a very spirited and heated
debate at times i want to thank you
out there for tuning in and looking
forward to seeing you again next week
for a new edition of quadriga
you